there are dangerous hate groups in
America who will warn us about them the
media haven't answered the Southern
Poverty Law Center the Southern Poverty
Law Center the Southern Poverty Law
Center based in that building in Alabama
calls itself the premier group
monitoring hate groups looking at their
map of such groups you'd think America
was consumed by hate I once believed in
the Center's mission well-meaning people
still do Apple just gave them a million
dollars but what donors don't know is
that today the center smears people who
don't deserve to be smeared the presence
of frat eco Islam this woman grew up in
Somalia suffered female genital
mutilation so now she speaks out against
radical Islam for that the center put
her on its list multiculturalism failed
these communities this man was once an
Islamic extremist but then he decided
radical Islam was wrong and now he
criticizes the radicals the center
labels human anti Muslim extremists to
join the fight against hate and bigotry
visit SPL center.org I do think that we
have a problem with hate in this country
we put about 10 of these major hate
groups out of business the center's
leaders Richard Cohen and Morris Dees
would not talk to me so commentator no
Mickey Kant stepped up to defend them
they had a history a long history of
fighting against extremists like the KKK
history yes but they labeled skeptical
Muslims like ayaan Hirsi Ali is haters
if you have a horrible experience with
religion that's one thing it's another
thing to use as experience as ammunition
against others who are practicing their
religion peacefully but they're just
speaking criticizing it
of course she is the right to free
speech as does the Southern Poverty Law
Center has a right to push back we can
stand together against hate the center
also calls the Family Research Council a
hate group the definition of a marriage
is what it's been for 5,000 years
it's the union of a man and a
I often disagree with the council myself
but do they belong in this hate map when
they don't agree with you politically
they're gonna list you as a hater you
are haters you hate gays no I don't hate
gay people and and and I know gay people
and I have worked with gay people but
once you're labeled a hate group you
become a target developing now word of a
shooting at the Family Research Council
there in Washington one man was so
enraged by what the center said about
the Family Research Council he went to
their headquarters to kill people
a man shot a security guard in the arm
fortunately that guard stopped the man
before he could shoot anyone else he
told the judge that he was there to kill
as many of us as possible because we
were a hate group the council's offices
were attacked by a guy with a gun I mean
they don't deserve this
there's always extremists out there and
it's unfortunately the world that we
live in and and you know hopefully
people can kind of separate that the
center also smears the Ruth Institute a
Christian group that believes gays
should not have an equal right to adopt
children they're not haters I like gay
people I've no problem with gay people
that's not the issue the issue is what
are we doing with kids and the
definition of who counts as a parent
what if a gay couple had a civil union
and adopted kids there could be cases
where the best person for a particular
child would be their uncle Harry and his
boyfriend you know that could be but we
owe it to the children to give them the
best we can which generally is a married
mother and father so you're a hater when
the center put her on it's hate map the
Ruth Institute's Bank sent her this
letter we've determined that you're an
organization that promotes hate violence
harassment and so therefore we're not
doing business with you and we went and
checked our website and we were already
down the Ruth Institute and the Family
Research Council are still on the hate
list there's no appeal I sure don't know
how you get off I suspect the center
keeps its hate lists long because crying
hate brings in lots of money Morris Dees
is salary is more than my entire annual
budget so yeah whatever they're doing it
pays years ago harper's magazine
reported that the center is the
wealthiest civil rights group in Amer
one that spent most of its time and
money on a fundraising campaign now
Morris Dees did once promised to stop
fundraising once his endowment hit fifty
five million dollars but when he reached
55 million he changed that to a hundred
million saying that would allow them to
cease costly fundraising but when they
reached a hundred million they didn't
stop today and they have an endowment
that now is over three hundred and
twenty million dollars much of witches
and offshore camps caimans and places
like that and how do you know oh we look
at their 990s and it says cayman islands
yeah
they pay some of their people more than
four hundred thousand seventeen it costs
a lot of money to exist in this world
give me a break the Southern Poverty Law
Center now lists people like Ben Carson
Laura Ingraham and Jeanne puro as
extremists but it doesn't list and Tifa
the hate group that beats up people on
the right the center has become a hate
group itself it's now a left-wing
money-grabbing
slander machine
you